[Musique]
une délégation chinoise se trouve
actuellement à la réunion afin de
visiter les différents musées de ce
jeudi 25 juillet ils ont été reçus à la
villa du département puis se sont
vendues au musée léon dierx situé rue de
paris c'est un très grand honneur
d'avoir pu recevoir au niveau du
département
l'un délégation de taiwan et le
département honore toujours les
délégations chinoises et toutes les
délégations des îles de l'océan indien
et les pays de la zone qui viennent ici
est d'autant plus ce que c'est vraiment
des personnes qui sont imprégnés bras
culture par la recherche et aussi par
l'archéologie
donc c'était vraiment un grand plaisir
pour le département est en tout cas pour
moi de recevoir cette délégation ici au
musée léon dierx
[Musique]